Billie Eilish.
Teenage pop sensation,
first musician born in this
century to get a No. 1 single,
the female artist to log
the second most Hot 100 songs at one time,
and ASMR icon?
Yep, one look at YouTube will tell you
just how popular Billie
is in the ASMR community.
The platform is full of
ASMR-inspired covers,
or whisper tributes, of her music.
There's a reason Billie's a
favorite of the ASMR crowd.
Her music uses key principles of ASMR
to redefine the sound of
pop, and that's the secret
to why she's the industry's
fastest-rising superstar.
ASMR is short for
autonomous sensory meridian response,
the brain tingles people feel
around the head and spine
in response to certain triggers.
Some of the most common
triggers are whispering.
Producer: Deep stretch.
Let's breathe in and out.
Narrator: Rhythmic sounds and movements,
and crisp, amplified acoustics.
Producer: Plastic bottle.
[tapping]
Of hand sanitizer.
Narrator: You can also find these elements
in Billie's music.
♪ Walk in wearing fetters ♪
♪ Peter should know better ♪
♪ So you're a tough guy ♪
♪ Like it really rough guy ♪
♪ Just can't get enough guy ♪
♪ Don't ask questions ♪
♪ You don't wanna know ♪
Gibi: In "Bury a Friend,"
she definitely, like,
the voice quality is
what sticks out to me.
You know, she's saying,
like, "I wanna end me."
♪ I wanna ♪
♪ I wanna end me ♪
It's, like, almost like a whisper,
and it gives you the chills.
Narrator: This is Gibi,
who The New York Times
described as "the LeBron
James of touching stuff."
She's an ASMR creator with
over 2 million subscribers
on her YouTube channel,
and like many ASMRtists,
she's also a big Billie fan.
In March, when the singer
dropped her debut LP,
"When We All Fall Asleep, Where Do We Go?"
her label reached out to
Gibi and commissioned her
to do an ASMR read-through
of Billie's album.
Gibi: [whispering] What do you know?
Why aren't you scared of me?
Why do you care for me?
It sounds like she is right up on the mic
and just, like, barely
letting the sound out,
and she sounds gorgeous.
♪ Into your ocean eyes ♪
Narrator: That hushed,
tingly, whisper quality
of Billie's voice?
♪ Don't you know too much already? ♪
Narrator: It's supposed
to sound like that.
According to Billie's sound mixer,
when it comes to her vocals,
"everything is close-mic'd and whispered."
The goal, he says, is to always
have Billie's vocals
sound "super-present."
It's as if she's right there,
murmuring directly into your ear.
Another thing Billie seems
to share with ASMRtists
is a passion for foley sound.
To produce a range of different
sounds for their followers,
ASMR creators borrow a lot of
techniques from foley artists,
the people that recreate
everyday sound effects
for movies and TV.
[crunching]
Similarly, Billie and her
brother-slash-producer, Finneas,
DIY a lot of the sound
effects they use in her songs.
The metallic scraping
sound that marks the upbeat
of "You Should See Me in a Crown"?
[metallic scrape]
That's a recording of
Finneas sharpening a knife.
[metallic scrape]
♪ Visions I vandalize ♪
And the horror-movie sound
of a whizzing drill in "Bury a Friend?"
♪ Calling security, keeping my head held ♪
Billie captured that
on her phone at a dentist appointment.
[whooshing]
To some people, the
sounds of a dentist office
might seem more nightmarish than relaxing,
but dentist role-plays are
actually very common in ASMR.
Gibi: [whispering] The mirror tool.
[light whirring]
Narrator: And so are many types
of drilling sounds, from dental drills
[light, high-pitched drilling]
to power drills.
[loud drilling]
Then there's the intro to Billie's album,
which opens with a surprisingly loud
and slightly gross recording of Billie
sucking the saliva out of her Invisalign.
[plastic tapping and slurping]
Those kinds of wet, slurpy mouth sounds
will be familiar to any fans
of the video genre mukbang,
which means "broadcast eating" in Korean.
[slurping]
There's a major ASMR
component to mukbang videos,
as they often involve a
lot of very loud slurping,
which some ASMR fans find hypnotic.
[slurping and smacking]
Whether mouth noises are your thing
or you like to stick with paper crinkling
and finger tapping,
chances are you're listening
to ASMR through headphones
if you want to get the optimal effect.
And the same goes for Billie's music.
The singer's been called
"the first pop star made for AirPods."
Gibi: When you do listen to
Billie Eilish with headphones,
you can hear all of the
instruments and the beats,
and everything sounds like
its own individual thing,
and I could totally see where
that is similar to the sounds
or, like, the layered sort
of technique that a lot
of ASMRtists use when they
find a pleasant sound.
So, like, you know, if it's
something like her snapping:
♪ I like it when you take control ♪
Or just, like, a really simple beat.
[crisp beat]
Narrator: Crisp sounds, which
are among the most common
ASMR triggers, are also a key
part of Billie's production.
♪ Out ♪
The clean base and minimal percussion
that form the skeleton of her beats
leave plenty of space for her
unusual sounds and samples.
♪ Sleeping ♪
♪ You're on your tippy toes, creeping ♪
Take the song "Bad Guy," for example.
Where you'd usually have a snare drum
keeping the song's pulse,
there are just soft
yet super-amplified finger snaps.
♪ Bruises on both my knees for you ♪
♪ Don't say thank you or please I do ♪
There are also strategic gaps of silence
to emphasize the weirdest
moments in the song,
like at the end of the
chorus, when Billie's voice
suddenly breaks up into
a million little pieces,
making it sound like
she's croaking into a fan.
♪ I'm the bad guy ♪
Gibi: You can catch all of
the tiny sounds and noises,
so it feels extremely immersive.
Compared to other music that
maybe is, like, a little
more flat, I feel like
Billie's music is extremely 3D.
Narrator: A big reason Billie's music
sounds so three-dimensional
is that her mixes
are specially crafted to dance
from one of your ears to the other.
When her voice splits up
into two or three tracks,
it sounds like you have a
different Billie in each ear.
♪ Pearly gates look more
like a picket fence ♪
♪ Once you get inside them ♪
♪ Got friends but can't invite them ♪
♪ Hills burn in California ♪
♪ My turn to ignore ya ♪
Narrator: In the final riff of "Bad Guy,"
you'll notice her
bouncing from left to
right in your headphones.
♪ I'm only good at being bad ♪
Narrator: This is what's known in ASMR
as the stereo effect, or binaural effect,
binaural meaning two ears.
ASMRtists use special techniques
to produce this effect
for their listeners.
[light scratching]
Gibi: You are using a microphone
that can track your movements,
or, in my case, I would
use two microphones.
I kinda want to talk a
little bit more about
the mall situation.
Where I grew up, the mall
and the movie theater
were right next to each other.
If I get closer to the right one,
you hear it more in your right ear.
Closer to the left, you
hear it in your left ear,
and it really helps with immersion
and making everything sound more intimate,
like you're right there
and the music or the sounds
of ASMR is happening around you.
Narrator: So Billie takes a page
out of the ASMR playbook
by trying to simulate
the acoustics of a 3D
environment in her music,
and this makes listening to
her a full-sensory experience,
which, at times, can get pretty intense.
Gibi: In "Xanny," she has
the ear-to-ear movements.
If you're wearing headphones,
it sounds like she's going back and forth.
♪ I don't need a Xanny ♪
Which is really interesting because
it's sort of paired with the
distortion in the same song,
which is, like, actually loudly
uncomfortable to listen to.
Narrator: It's probably because her voice
often sounds like it's encircling you.
Many people find watching ASMR
videos unsettling at first
for the very same reason.
It sometimes feels like
the person in the video
is physically in the room with you,
but that intense intimacy
might be the secret
behind the power of both
ASMR and Billie's music.
ASMR is thought to be
related to a phenomenon
called "frisson," named after
the French word for "shiver."
Often, frisson is most
closely associated with music.
Music-induced frisson refers
to the pleasurable chills
that some people may experience
while listening to a song,
like the goosebumps or
shivers that Billie fans
often describe getting from her music.
The most well-developed theory
about music-induced frisson
comes from a music cognitive
psychologist named David Huron.
This theory states that frisson
is actually related to fear.
According to this theory,
when a song contains
a surprising element of some kind,
like a sharp and unusual sound effect...
[metallic scraping]
♪ Step on the glass ♪
♪ Staple your tongue ♪
♪ Bury a friend ♪
Or a voice that suddenly sounds
like it's jumping around in space...
♪ Don't give me a Xanny now ♪
That provokes an instinctual fear response
in your brain.
This defensive reflex is so short-lived,
it probably won't reach consciousness,
because, in short, the
rational part of your brain
recognizes there's no threat
and quickly inhibits your fear center.
That's when you'd feel the tingles.
It's the suppression of your
fear that's so pleasurable.
OK, so what does this have to do with ASMR
and with Billie's music?
Well, because ASMR
closely resembles frisson,
some scientists believe it
might be set off the same way,
but with a different initial fear cue.
One possibility is that
what brings the tingles
when you're watching an ASMR video
is the perception of physical closeness
with the person creating the sounds.
Because of the acoustic techniques
that many ASMR creators use
and the feeling of intimacy
that they cultivate,
it can feel, at times,
like they're entering your personal space,
something that makes
humans and most animals
go into high alert.
Billie's vocals and soundscapes
create the same unnerving
sense of closeness.
♪ Drinking you down like I wanna drown ♪
♪ Like I wanna end me ♪
♪ Step on the glass ♪
♪ Staple your tongue ♪
Essentially, her music is designed
to make your brain and body react.
It combines the musical cues
that are linked to frisson
with the physical cues that
may well be linked to ASMR.
There are a lot of unexpected
musical events in Billie's songs.
The startling sound effects
[ringing]
and new vocal harmonies that
seem to come out of nowhere,
then there's all the sonic trickery that
makes her voice sound like
it's moving around spatially,
sometimes even approaching
or surrounding you.
It creates that illusion of proximity.
The almost-too-close-for-comfort feeling
that you'd get from an ASMR video.
Billie Eilish combines
all of these techniques
to make some of the most
spine-tingling music
to ever hit mainstream,
and if her smash debut is any indication,
this tingly sound just
might be the future of pop.
♪ My Lucifer is lonely ♪